bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous ce matin sur
rtl france alors en matière de politique
étrangère les observateurs sont à peu
près tous unanimes à part le plan de
relance européen et une vaccination
commune à l'union européenne
le bilan des manuels maquereau en
matière de politique étrangère reste
quasi nul est ce que c'est le cas quel
bilan en faites-vous je commence par
vous fadila mehal est ce que c'est juste
ce constat
d'abord je tiens à préciser que je suis
ici en tant que société civile en tant
que vice présidente de l'institut robert
schuman nous défendons la société civile
dans l'europe et il n'est pas question
pour moi de faire un bilan d'un
versement en tout cas dans l'exécutif
est-ce que c'est pas c'est pas l'objet
par contre ce que je peux vous dire
c'est sur l'europe aujourd'hui je
pensais que le débat porterait sur cette
question là puisque bon allez quand même
traversé par de nombreuses inquiétudes
on le voit mais il me semble
qu'aujourd'hui la démonstration était
faite d'ailleurs les dernières élections
européennes ont montré massivement
l'attachement des français à l'europe
tél évidemment avec les réformes qui
s'imposent tout le monde a parlé de la
beauronne précise à sion la difficulté
d'arriver finalement à des projets
communs je pense notamment sur la
question de la défense européenne je
crois que ça c'est quand même un angle
mort aujourd'hui qui font observer pour
le reste je pense que nous devons
avancer dans c'est dans ces situations
je suis très très sensible aux questions
sociétales et notamment à la place des
femmes aujourd'hui et je remarque
puisque nous sommes pas bientôt allant
du 25e du 25 pardon novembre qui scelle
finalement la question des violences
faites aux femmes que c'est grâce à
l'euro grâce à l'europe que ces
questions en tout cas de l'égalité
hommes femmes sont posées que la
question de la discrimination a été
posée puisque c'est bien le traité de
rome qui dès 1906 cette a posé comme
postulat l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes et on voit aujourd'hui que
cette question en tout cas vous parler
de bilan g11 géopolitique mais moi je
vous parle de bilan aussi sociétaux qui
lie à des reculs fondamentaux en europe
et notamment dans certains pays laissent
je pense à la langue gris sur les
questions de l'avortement sur la
question de l'intégrité des corps des
femmes je crois que c'est très important
que l'europe soit le socle des valeurs
sur lequel les valeurs humanistes
évidemment que je défends l'institut
robert schuman puisse continuer à
fonctionner et de ce point de vue le
bilan est très très positif puisque
c'est en 2000 yeux je crois que c'est en
2009 avec le traité de lisbonne que la
double discrimination a été érigée en
principe est que ça a permis d'ailleurs
à
l'est parfois il faut le dire des excès
puisque vous parlez j'ai vu tout à
l'heure dans le reportage je vous
évoquer la question du voile et la
notion de laïcité qui n'est pas vécue de
façon identique en europe et en france
et qui permet en tout cas de confronter
les points de vue mais moi j'assure que
le bilan en tout cas européen sur ces
questions là est fondamentalement
positif grâce à emmanuel macron selon
vous un fêtes de laméac après je me
poserai la question annexe à elles mêmes
une macro avec marlène schiappa vous
savez bien qu'il a mis en évidence est
en tout cas en pratique des éléments
extrêmement fort par rapport aux gens
prend pour preuve tout ce qui a été mis
en place avec les grenelles eu des
violences faites aux femmes avec le bras
bracelet avait deux noms
avec baldolini rovère avec le nombre qui
a crû de 2 centres d'hébergement qui
vous l'avez vu aujourd'hui la parole
s'est libérée alors pas grâce à une
macro mais quand vous rentrez quand vous
êtes victime de violences conjugales ou
intra conjugales et que vous rentrez
dans un commissariat et que vous êtes
reçus avec empathie et ils n'ont pas de
l'eau avec un regard oblique et bien je
pense que ça change beaucoup sur cette
parole et moi je suis fond d'amour elles
m'ont convaincue que les femmes doivent
beaucoup à leur homme sur cette volonté
en tout cas d'arrivée les choses en
terme d'égalité vous savez hier le 3
novembre à 9h22 les femmes travailler
pour rien avec moi si
on a bien compris l'égalité salariale
ouais on a fait un des bailleurs 10% on
a fait un débat sur justement dans les
conditions des femmes hier dans ce dans
cette même matinale verte et france on
va essayer d'élargir un petit peu quand
même sur la vision qu'ont les candidats
de cette europe je me tourne vers vous
maxence briquet on a vu les adieux de
des bagnoles macro à angola merkel hier
un commentaire
ben vous disiez que le bilan de
politique étrangère des massacres ont
été quasiment nulle j'imagine au sens de
l'absence de choses moi je dirais qu'il
est quasiment nul et même presque
totalement nuls en termes d'efficacité
c'est à dire que les adieux d'angela
merkel puisque vous en parlez c'est
finalement les adieux à quelqu'un qui a
une femme qui a eu des positions très
intéressant pour l'allemagne qui a
permis de l'allemagne de se relever et
économiquement qui a baissé la tva qui
est de redonner de la compétitivité à
l'industrie allemande qui est
aujourd'hui un des moteurs de son
économie mais à côté de ça en gala
merkel s'est aussi des échecs cuisants
c'est l'élu millions de migrants qui
sont arrivés en allemagne et vous
parliez madame du droit des femmes je
suis pas sûr que les femmes qui ont été
violées à cologne soin de votre avis
concernant la bienveillance européenne
en la matière l'allemagne c'est aussi le
pays qui est qui est en train de sortir
du nucléaire donc qui est en train de
complètement zappé nos objectifs
climatiques qu'en france on est quand
même bien parti pour atteindre avec
notre mix électrique donc je pense pour
ma part que le vit dans des manuels
macro est absolument désastreux et que
son son européisme bea est en train de
me coûter écouter beaucoup parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est proposé par l
exercer le fait de se dire que la france
ne sera plus le moteur en fait de cette
forme d'intégration européenne qui ni
l'identité des peuples et qui nie les
nations on essaye de faire un espèce de
bulle il ya en se basant sur la butte où
c'était une espèce de de marché
aujourd'hui l'union européenne s'est
construite sur le marché si sur le droit
le marché d'une part c'est une sorte de
libéralisme à sens unique en fait parce
que si je prends l'exemple des marchés
publics tous les phares les chinois les
américains ont accès de manière
complètement illimité à nos marchés
publics voilà où nous n'avons absolument
pas accès aux leurs donc on fait preuve
d'une naïveté absolument confondante
naïveté dont des manières maquereau a
lui même fait preuve en matière
économique récemment avec l'histoire des
sous marins australiens et aussi en
termes de défense vise à vider des
rafales qui était censé être vendue à la
suisse 1 qui ne l'ont pas été parce
qu'on a été incapable de défendre
l'industrie militaire ramallah pour le
constat marine le pen je vous en prie
vous pouvez répondre vous laisser dire
je peux pas vous le dire ça parce que
bon le vide aux élus la brèche par la
porte-parole de la reine bien qu ayant
appartenu à son goût ce que je peux vous
dire c'est quand on lit les article sur
le goudron le bilan des manuels
maquereau en maître en matière de
politique étrangère se fonder des
experts se sont pas des dd des hommes
politiques qui font ce constat en termes
d'action concrète qui sort aujourd'hui
je réponds à votre interlocuteur sur la
question de l'immigration que je connais
bien c'est un sujet très important on
oublie de dire que l'europe en tout cas
n'a pas eu lieu et c'est leur offre dans
sa totalité
pensez à une politique migratoire à
l'échelle européen la preuve vous voyez
à ce qui se passe à calais c'est la
france qui aujourd'hui à sur les
frontières pour le compte de
l'angleterre et pour lequel d'ailleurs
avec des difficultés extrêmement
importantes d'eau qui a une vraie
réflexion à mener mais qui n'est pas
imputable à l'instant seulement en tout
cas passé gouvernement sur ce champ là
j'ajoute que sur le sujet de
l'immigration où j'ai vu j'ai suivi de
très près la question de des réfugiés et
je peux vous assurer que en tout cas les
réformes qui ont été entreprises sur le
droit d'asile c'est des réformes
fondamentales vous savez qu'il y a avant
l'avènement de 2,2 de macron il y avait
un temps d'attentes plus de quatre ans
pour pouvoir bénéficier d'une réponse
qu'elle soit si vous qu'elle soit
négative meilleure réponse aujourd'hui
le délai a été raccourci à six mois donc
évidemment à ce sont des mesures abah
abah abah
attend pas et mais qui saurait elle est
donc je peux il faut absolument je pense
donc dans la zone étaient du propos dire
tout ce qui est imputable véritablement
à la politique française est ce qu'il
est peut-être à la paralysie en tout cas
la frilosité de tous les états mans à
ceci étant je pense il ya des délais
raccourcis vous aider mais les
raccourcis fadila mais la mémé dans le
même temps des pays européens la mise
des murs
maxence briquet réponse
jusqu usées moi je vais juste me
répondre sur sur la question de l'europe
parce qu'évidemment l'europe on ne lui a
pas confié fort heureusement la question
de la gestion de la politique migratoire
sûr qu'on est elle en train de se la
roja mais comme beaucoup de compétences
avec la primauté du droit européen sur
le droit national et vous dites que
l'union européenne en fait est en train
de
finalement de jouer un rôle assez
important dans la conscience cugnaux
rockets que la question des gars thouars
sera elle aussi au niveau européen sauf
qu'en fait aujourd'hui elle serait d'une
seule manière ce sont les juges
européens qui lancent des injonctions
aux pays comme l'italie en leur
interdisant de refouler les migrants à
leurs frontières donc c'est une sorte de
négation de la souveraineté des peuples
parce qu'aujourd'hui que vous avez quand
même énormément de pays qui sont en
accord avec ce qu'a pensé avec zemmour
en fait parce que vous avez y avait un
très bon papier dans le figaro et qui
était sorti la semaine dernière où la
semaine d'avant qui disait qu'il y avait
en gros 11 12 et à l est est aujourd'hui
en train de faire les gros yeux à
bruxelles entend sans leur politique
migratoire et en disant qu'il n'en
voulait plus donc c'est pour ça aussi
que avec un argument en fait on n'a pas
envie de quitter l'union européenne ni
l'euro d'ailleurs assez c'est un procès
qui nous est faussement fait parce qu'en
fait on voit très bien que le vent est
en train de tourner et que ce serait
dommage de quitter le navire alors qu'on
est en train d'en prendre le
commandement s'ils utilisent l fadila
mehal oui je vous interrogez vous me
disiez que leur a pas laissé beaucoup
pourrait faciliter les procédures
raccourcir les délais pour les demandes
d'asile mais dans le même temps on le
voit bien des pays d'europe même
l'allemagne renforcent ses frontières
aujourd'hui
nom de la france je parle pas de
l'europe puisque là c'est une une gelée
dire une responsabilité nationale la
france a fait beaucoup courir pour
raccourcir à peu les délais alors sur la
question de l'immigration écouter on
peut dire ce qu'on veut maintenant la
réalité est celle là c'est à dire qu'il
y à alençon tiers dans le mot un
développement de toute façon de plus en
plus fort pour les mobilités les
mobilités elles sont d'ordre planétaire
elles sont dues au changement climatique
vous allez avoir des réfugiés
climatiques de plus en plus alors vous
pouvez tout à fait dire on va m'aider
barbelés et on va fermer toutes les
frontières et ne serait pas question de
laisser revenir quand en même temps
quand en même temps l'économie
aujourd'hui crient famine et demandent
des bras ce qu'il n'y a pas assez pour
déjà les dires des filières extrêmement
tendu il n'y a pas assez de bras donc je
pense qu'il faut à ne pas voir une ré
réaction une réflexion passionnel sur le
sujet ce que je sais que vous êtes
adepte du grand remplacement mais
réfléchir de façon très efficace à
comment aujourd'hui résoudre les
problèmes économiques comment résoudre
les problèmes démographiques y sont en
train de se reposer et enfin résoudre
aussi les problèmes qui sont de
l'éthique mans aujourd'hui nous avons
signé des conventions par rapport aux
réfugiés conventions internationales qui
font que la france est une terre d'asile
que vous le vouliez ou non il faut
respecter ces valeurs là alors après
évidemment tous ces mets quand les
afghans sont dans une situation
pitoyable à cause du fanatisme at aigri
mais en même temps personne ne veut
aujourd'hui accueillir ces femmes et
elles sont nombreuses qui sont victimes
je dirais victime presque physique de
ses agissements legault quand il faut
choisir un nom il ne reste pas beaucoup
de temps chaud de la merde je voulais
avancer un petit peu sur la dernière
question maxence briquet sur cette
question des réfugiés en loi ou
d'ailleurs a calé en ce moment là même
la maire de calais ne veut pas d'un
centre d'accueil pour pour résoudre
cette question qu'en pensez vous
ben je suis tout à fait d'accord en fait
lorsque madame disait déjà en disant que
les réfugiés sont des réfugiés
climatiques c'est simon paraît enfin en
tout cas pas pour l'instant à terme je
ne dis pas mais
ils vivent pour l'instant madame ce ne
sont pas des réfugiés climatiques et
lorsque lens qui suivent être arriverons
là et surtout chose madame minata le
grand concert
c'est vrai que à distance c'est
compliqué on n'entend personne du coup
fait de l'émotionnel madame
vous essayez de nous de nous faire dire
que c'est vrai on peut pas laisser ces
gens là dans une situation terrible en
fait ce cas aussi des français de souche
trouver des solutions mais les mêlées
simulées
mais on a des solutions viables madame
la première solution viable c'est de
tenir nos frontières pour éviter qu'on
est des dizaines de milliers de
clandestins qui arrivent en france et
qui menacent la population française il
ya deux ans nous parle et fédère
d'économies pour dire que l'union
européenne était une solution union
européenne a été une solution a rien de
tout ça aujourd'hui lorsqu'on a des
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat sur
l'énergie c'est le marché unique
européen si la foudre concurrence qui
était imposé adf qui est en cause
lorsqu'on a des problèmes de logistique
en france avec par exemple le fret
ferroviaire qui a été mise à bas par la
concurrence dans le fret en 2005 si
l'union européenne encore une fois qui
était derrière tout ça lorsqu'on parle
de la stratégie vaccinale c'est un échec
lorsqu'on a voulu avoir un vaccin
européen on n'y est pas arrivé alors que
les anglais ont bien argent
menstruations attaque les américains
aussi on a refusé de financer ça lui en
fait l'europe est compilé complètement à
la traîne et est-ce que je skie emmanuel
macron et à ma chronique managériale du
mal à comprendre c'est qu'en fait ce
sont les initiatives individuelles qui
font tout c'est pas le l'union
européenne les grandes messes
médiatiques nous vend en ce moment avec
la cop16 qui vont essayer de faire
changer les choses ce sont les
initiatives individuelles quant à titre
d'exemple plus fait les annales jeunesse
le mois de la fin parce que vraiment il
nous reste très très peu de temps
oui je voulais simplement dire que
j'avais l'impression que monsieur récite
sa leçon comme ça de façon déconnecté
moi j'étais une élue du xviiie
arrondissement le xviiie arrondissement
c'est le coeur de l'immigration
aujourd'hui et c'est par là qu'ils
arrivent et je peux vous dire que les
oui mais que les choses qui ont aimé
rennais moissac des choses concrètes que
je connais parce que vous n'avez jamais
mis les pieds sur le terrain monsieur
moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
ça dégénère
c'est pas des crimes général tellement
beau temps on nous allons millions c'est
ma série d'accueil qui a permis
d'accueillir dans la dignité ces
personnes et de permettre après leur
mobilité au niveau de toute la france là
bas ce sera ce sera le héros de la
bosnie la réal ce sera une légère
poussée de la fin il a pu le temps
malheureusement on va parler de
politique étrangère dans un autre débat
ce sera la semaine prochaine
merci beaucoup en tout cas à tous les
deux évidemment un débat animé dès qu'il
s'agit d' immigration